i saw how you opened the show now with
the tribute to charlie you're late
drummer and i found it fascinating what
you did before you guys come on there's
big screens and you see charlie up there
but it's funny what you chose to show of
charlie drumming is a very sort of
steady
beat
it wasn't as fancy as phil it wasn't
some
crazy drum solo it really said this is
the guy who was the heartbeat of our
band he
kept pace right that's that's the point
of what you're doing mm-hmm uh during
the tour it's a heartbeat you know i
mean charlie was a heartbeat for the
band you know and also a very steady
personality you know it's very um
reliable person you know wasn't a diva
you know that's the last thing you want
in the drama
right look so
charlie was a very subtle drama and he
you know it was everyone says it what
charlie was love was jazz he loved jazz
he did love jazz and and and that gave
him the subtlety uh
that perhaps that he wouldn't have had
if he hadn't been such a student and and
also played jazz a lot but you know he
was a rock drummer as well you know he
was a
he was a steady rock drummer he wasn't
just a jazz drummer showing off or
trying to be too technical and muslims
very had a very sort of dry sense of
humor
and and um you know he's a wonderful guy
to play but i mean we
you know i miss charlie because you know
he had a great sense of humor and and we
we also were
outside of the band you know we used to
hang out quite a lot and have
interesting times going we like sports
we go to
football we'd go to cricket games and we
would have other interests apart from
just music um and but you know of course
i'm you know really
miss charlie so much um you know being
up there playing and and every time we
get together now and rehearse we always
think oh yeah and charlie would say this
don't know
then he would do that and he would i
mean he was very quirky guy and um you
know we really miss him but you know we
did so many shows with him and and so
many tours with him and so many
recording sessions it's it's uh you know
strange being without him but when he
was sick he said well you know you've
got to just carry on and do this tour
you know you don't stop because of me so
so we did
[Applause]
you